foreign
a very lucky candidate from the outside
is selected for admission to this
hallowed Institution
it's happening
we've been expecting you
School for Good and Evil
with a true story behind every great
fairy tale Begins the school for good
trains the heroes
the school for evil the villains
you're trying to tell me that Snow White
and Cinderella and Jack and the
Beanstalk were real
the very real events which become the
stories
that changed the world
this is all I've ever wanted Aggie can
settle for an ordinary life not as it
seems
but we don't belong here oh dear you
must be lost that is an understatement
future heroes and villains the time has
come for you to admit which side you're
on
tired of being pathetic little Sophie
you can be more than you ever dreamed
you could be
[Music]
you'll not just be the fairest of them
all
you'll be the strongest
the rules at this school must be obeyed
dangerous evil is here we have to
protect Sophie
Sophie becomes
none of us will survive I'm your best
friend evil is controlling you
me
[Music]
I thought fairies were supposed to be
nice
[Music]